>> Tucker: SO IN THE THREE OR
SO YEARS THAT WE'VE TAKEN UP A
DOZEN DIFFERENT PROVISIONS AND
TOPICS BUT ONE THING WE HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN CONSISTENT ABOUT
FROM THE FIRST DAY UNTIL TODAY
IS MAKING FUN OF
BILL de BLASIO ON EVERY TOPIC.
IF YOU WATCH THE SHOW, YOU WOULD
KNOW.
THEN THE OTHER DAY I CAME TO OUR
ATTENTION THAT BLOWS IO HAS
RAISED AN ISSUE THAT TOO FEW IN
EITHER PARTY HAVE RAISED A
QUESTION ABOUT PAID AUTOMATION.
HE IS ALSO RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, SOMETHING ELSE WE
MADE FUN OF BUT HIS POSITION ON
AUTOMATION STRUCK US ON A
STRING.
IF WE ARRANGE A PHONE CALL AND
HAD A VERY FRIENDLY CONVERSATION
AND INVITED HIM TO COME ON THE
SHOW AND TALK ABOUT THAT ANOTHER
THING IS THAT HE WAS RIGHTEOUS
AND AFTER HIS BOND AND SO WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE MARRIED
BILL de BLASIO JOIN US TONIGHT
LIVE.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE YOU CARE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT SPRANG
DOWN ON ALL OF US.
>> Tucker: IT IS AND MY PRAISE
OF YOU ON THIS QUESTION IS
TOTALLY SINCERE.
VERY FEW PEOPLE ARE TAKEN AS
SERIOUSLY.
ANDREW YANG IS ONE OF THEM.
YOU ARE ANOTHER AND I CAN'T
THINK OF MANY OTHERS THAT ARE
AND SO GOD BLESS YOU.
YOU ARE BASICALLY SAYING THAT
COMPANIES OUGHT TO HAVE TWO --
AND I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH I
AGREE WITH THIS BUT I THINK I'M
PRAISING THIS CURTSY.
USE A COMPANIES OUGHT TO HAVE TO
BEAR SOME OF THE COST OF HELPING
WORKERS TRANSITION INTO
SOMETHING ELSE WHEN THEY LAY
THEM OFF IN FAVOR OF ROBOTS?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
RIGHT NOW, LET'S JUST GET THE
MAGNITUDE CLEAR FOR ALL OF YOUR
VIEWERS.
MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICANS,
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS WHOSE
JOBS ARE NOT GOING TO BE THERE
IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
RIGHT NOW THE RECENT ESTIMATE I
SAW, 36 MILLION JOBS THAT COULD
BE MADE OBSOLETE, WE ARE TALKING
AS EARLY AS 2030, 12 YEARS
AHEAD, 11, 12 YEARS FROM NOW, SO
HERE'S THE REALITY.
RIGHT NOW THE FEDERAL TAX COURT
REWARDS COMPANIES THAT INVEST IN
THE KIND OF TECHNOLOGY THAT
ACTUALLY SHEDS JOBS.
DESTROYS JOBS.
IF OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE HELPING
COMPANIES AND INTENT SENT
DEVISING COMPANIES TO GET RID OF
MORE AMERICAN WORKERS SO MY PLAN
IS SIMPLE.
END OF THAT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE
COULD USE TO ACTUALLY ADDRESS
OUR BIGGER ISSUES.
>> Tucker: I AM COMPLETELY
WITH YOU.
I'M SURE THERE'S A LOT OF
DETAILS WE DISAGREE WITH BUT I
GO WITH YOU ON.
>> Tucker: BY THE MAY,
SOUTH KOREA IS DOING I MAY NOT
BE THE DON'T STOP INCENTIVIZING
COMPANIES.
A LOT OF TIMES THEY ARE MAKING A
DECISION SIMPLY BECAUSE IT'S
BETTER FOR THEIR TAX REALITY
RATHER THAN WHAT'S BETTER FOR
WORKING PEOPLE OR EVEN
PRODUCTIVITY.
THE SECOND POINT OF MY PLAN IS
LEAD INSTITUTIONS --
SOMETHING BILL GATES ACTUALLY
WAS I THINK THE FIRST WANT TO
CALL FOR, WHICH WAS QUOTE
UNQUOTE A ROBOT TEXAS SINCE
SIMPLY A WORKER PAYS INCOME TAX.
YOU TAKE AWAY MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF WORKERS, THAT'S A
LOT LESS REVENUE TO TAKE CARE OF
ALL THE THINGS WE NEED IN OUR
SOCIETY AND A MEANS OF COURSE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE A LIVELIHOOD.
I BELIEVE AND WORRY.
I THINK YOU DO TO YOU.
I THINK WE NEED A FUTURE BASED
ON WORK SO IF A COUNTRY IS GOING
TO PUT THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE OUT
OF WORK, THEY SHOWED A
RESPONSIBLY FOR MAKING SURE
THOSE FOLKS GET A NEW JOB AT THE
SAME COMPANY OR ELSEWHERE OR
THAT TAX IS AN INCENTIVE TO KEEP
PEOPLE ON THE JOB AND A GOOD WAY
AND A PRODUCTIVE WAY AND
PROVIDES MONEY TO HELP FOSTER
FROM THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE KINDS
OF THINGS WE NEED A LOT MORE.
INVESTMENT IN RENEWABLE ENERGY,
RECYCLING, ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTITUTION COME ALL SORTS OF
THINGS FOR ITS FUEL AND LET ME
ASK YOU THOUGH.
I'M NOT SURE I THINK OF THIS
SECOND BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S
TOTALLY CRAZY.
SO WE WERE TOGETHER UP UNTIL
THIS POINT BUT IF YOU REALLY
BELIEVE THAT AUTOMATION IS A
THREAT TO LOW SKILL JOBS, WHY
ARE YOU FOR MASS IMMIGRATION
QUESTION MIKE WHAT ARE THESE
PEOPLE GOING TO DO THAT WE ARE
IMPORTING QUESTION MEXICO LOOK.
I'M GOING TO FINISH THE POINT
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE HERE.
LET'S JUST BE CLEAR ABOUT THE
CENTRAL POINT HERE.
RIGHT NOW THERE IS NO AMERICAN
STRATEGY, NO FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS AUTOMATION
AND IT COULD BE THE SINGLE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FORCE IN OUR SOCIETY
THAT WE HAVE EVER EXPERIENCED.
IF WE TALK ABOUT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF MILLING
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS WHO NO
LONGER HAVE THE PROSPECT TO
WORK, THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE.
SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS TO
STEP UP.
THERE IS NO STRATEGY NOW, THERE
IS NO CANDIDATE IN MY OPINION
WHO IS OFFERING A COHERENT
STRATEGY.
>> Tucker: IMMIGRATION IS A
CLOSE SECOND AS A FORCE OF
TRANSFORMING THE COUNTRY AND THE
TWO ARE AT CROSS PURPOSES SO
IMMIGRANTS COME HERE
OVERWHELMINGLY TO WORK IN LOW
SKILL JOBS COME A LOT OF THOSE
JOBS NO MATTER HOW HARD WE TRY
HER GOING AWAY.
THIS IS CRAZY.
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
>> LET'S FACE IT, THERE'S A HUGE
NUMBER OF JOBS RIGHT NOW AND
LET'S TAKE AGRICULTURE IS AN
OBVIOUS EXAMPLE, WE ARE IN THE
WORST OF ALL WORLDS.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH WORKERS TO
DO THE WORK AMONG THE PEOPLE
ALREADY IN THIS COUNTRY AND WE
DON'T HAVE A COHERENT
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM INCLUDING
SOMETHING AS OBVIOUS AS A GUEST
WORKER PROGRAM, A LEGAL GUEST
WORKER PROGRAM.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
AND THAT'S A SEPARATE DEBATE.
I DISAGREE.
BUT THE MUCH BIGGER PICTURE
ISN'T JOBS IN THE SERVICE SECTOR
ARE GOING AWAY.
THAT IMMIGRANTS FILL.
IF WE IMPORT IMMIGRANTS, WHY ARE
WE DOING NOW?
>> I APPRECIATE YOUR POINT, BUT
THE MAGNITUDE HERE SPEAKS
OTHERWISE.
LET'S TAKE THAT NUMBER,
36 MILLION.
AND THERE ARE ESTIMATES TO GO A
LOT FURTHER THAN THAT.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE END
TIMES EMIGRATION.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING
ABSOLUTELY SEISMIC AND IMAGINE,
I THINK YOU AND I SHARED THIS
CONCERN.
ABOUT A HUGE PERCENTAGE OF YOUR
VIEWERS DO, TO PRINT HOW DO WE
HAVE A THREAT TO OUR SECURITY,
TO OUR STABILITY AS A COUNTRY,
TO OUR SOCIAL FABRIC AND THERE
IS NO STRATEGY WHATSOEVER.
IN FACT, THE RECENT TAX
LEGISLATION MADE IT WORSE AND
ENCOURAGE COMPANIES TO LAY OFF
MORE WORKERS AND TO PUT THE
MONEY INTO NEW MACHINES.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING IS THAT WE HAVE THIS
MASSIVE PROBLEM THAT EVERYONE IS
IGNORING.
AND ON THAT POINT I WANT TO
TRANSITION TO THE CITY THAT YOU
WANT, NEW YORK WHERE I WAS
YESTERDAY.
THE CITY IS DIRTY AND IT'S
GETTING DIRTIER.
IF ONE OF MY PRODUCERS TOLD ME
JUST YESTERDAY THAT HE WAS IN A
CROWDED SUBWAY AND DROPPED HIS
TROUSERS AND IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE CAR AND NO ONE DID ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT KID THAT'S A METAPHOR
FOR WHAT IS HAPPENING.
I GROW THERE REGULARLY AND I
HAVE MY WHOLE LIFE AND EVERY
TIME I GO UNDER YOUR MAYOR SHIP
IT IS DIRTIER, THERE IS FELT ON
THE SIDEWALKS, DO YOU NOTICE ANY
OF THAT?
>> LOOK.
HERE'S WHAT'S GOING ON IN
NEW YORK CITY TODAY.
WE HAVE CHALLENGES, NO DOUBT.
I DON'T EXPECT A SITUATION LIKE
THAT THAT I AM SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVES THE QUALITY OF LIFE HAS
TO BE ADDRESSED AGGRESSIVELY
BREAD I BELIEVE IN POLICING AND
I ALWAYS HAVE.
THAT KIND OF SITUATION IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
THE BIGGEST SITUATION, WE ARE AT
THOSE SAFEST BIG CITY IN
AMERICA.
IT IS PROVEN STATISTICALLY TIME
AND TIME AGAIN.
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF JOBS IN
OUR HISTORY AND THE STRONGEST
ECONOMY WE HAVE EVER HAD, WE
HAVE PROBLEMS UNQUESTIONABLY BUT
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF AREAS
WHERE THE CITY IS DOING VERY,
VERY WELL BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
HERE IS THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING --
>> Tucker: OKAY BUT YOU
ENDORSE DECRIMINALIZING PUBLIC.
IT WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO DO
THAT?
STICK OUT AS ABSOLUTELY FALSE.
ANY OFFENSE LIKE THAT'S GET SOME
IN AND THERE IS A PENALTY AND
SANCTION.
WE ALL BELIEVE IN HIM.
>> Tucker: YOU LINK IN THE
SANCTION.
THE CITY SMELLS LIKE YOU'RE IN.
YOU WILL NOTICE OUR CUSTOMERS TO
GET GLASS NOT SPEAK OF THE CITY
IS MORE ORDERLY AND CLEANER
AND SAFER THAN IT'S EVER BEEN
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS BUT WE ARE
MORE TO DO.
AND WE ARE GOING TO KEEP MAKING
IT BETTER BUT ANYONE THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
THAT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS
>> Tucker: YOU WANT THE
NUMBERS QUESTION MIKE I HAVE A
RIGHT HERE.
64,060 THE DAY YOU'RE PRETTY SET
OUT LEFT AND NOW IT'S HAVING THE
AIDE.
HE GOT OBVIOUSLY WE CAN REASON
TOGETHER.
THERE IS A FEDERAL ACCOUNT EVERY
YEAR FOR THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS
ON THE STREET.
IT'S GIVE OR TAKE 4,000.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
SHELTER SYSTEM, THAT'S TRUE.
WE ARE DRIVING DOWN THAT NUMBER.
I'M NOT HAPPY EVEN ABOUT 4,000
PEOPLE IN THE STREET BUT THAT'S
JUST NOWHERE NEAR WHAT YOU JUST
SAID BUT THE DIFFERENCE WHAT YOU
CAN SEE IN NEW YORK AND YOU CAN
SEE IN ON SAFETY AND YOU CAN SEE
IT ON JOBS AND YOU SEE ON A
HIGHER GRADUATION RATE IN OUR
SCHOOLS IS WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS IN THIS CITY AND WE ARE
GOING TO MAKE A LOT MORE BUT TO
THE ORIGINAL POINT OF THIS
CONVERSATION --
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU A
CONCRETE QUESTION.
IF I LIVE IN NEW YORK AND THERE
IS A HOMELESS MAN OUTSIDE OF MY
BUILDING WHO ON THE SIDEWALK, IS
ON THE SIDEWALK GROUNDS TO BE
ARRESTED IN THIS CITY?
>> IT CERTAINLY CAN BE AND
ANYONE WHO SEE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT --
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
IF I'M ON A SIDEWALK AND YOU
WILL BE ARRESTED FOR ON
PREVENTING FROM LIVING OUTSIDE?
>> ANYONE WHO IS A THREAT TO
THEMSELVES OR ANYONE WHO
VIOLATES THE LAW, ANYONE WHO IS
AGGRESSIVE TOWARDS OTHER PEOPLE,
THERE'S A WHOLE HOST OF
STANDARDS BY WHICH SOMEONE COULD
BE ARRESTED AND WE DO THAT AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
BUT AGAIN, THE BOTTOM LINE HERE
IS, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT REAL IS
IS, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT REAL IE
HERE BUT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE TIME IS
THE FUTURE OF THE WORKING
PEOPLE, THE FUTURE OF WORKING
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY AND WHERE
YOU AND I STARTED, IF WE DON'T
AND WE ARE TWO OF THE ONLY
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT ARRAY
KNOWN.
IF WE DON'T DEAL WITH THE FACT
THAT TENS OF MILLIONS OF WORKERS
MAY NOT HAVE A JOB AND WE MAY
HAVE A FUTURE WITHOUT WORK AND
OUR SOCIAL FABRIC TO BE
DESTROYED AND THAT'S A THREAT TO
AMERICA'S SUPERIORITY, THAT
WHICH WE DON'T DEAL WITH THIS IN
THE SELECTION, WE ARE GOING TO
RULE THE DAY.
WE ARE GOING TO RUE THE DAY.
WE NEED TO ACTUALLY DO SOME
THING ABOUT I.
>> Tucker: I AGREE AND AS AN
ESSENTIALLY NONPARTISAN PERSON I
AM ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO
COMPLEMENT YOU WITH TOTAL
SINCERITY ON THAT.
I'M JUST SAYING THAT REALITY,
THE ACTUAL REALITY OF LIFE IN
THE CITY THAT YOU MANAGE
MATTERS.
IT'S THE BIGGEST CITY IN OUR
COUNTRY GREAT I'VE LIVED THERE
ON AND OFF MY WHOLE LIFE.
THAT CITY IS NOT GETTING BETTER
UNDER YOUR MAYOR SHIP.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU LOOK
AT --
UNLESS YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN THE
NYPD STATISTICS WHICH
CONSISTENTLY --
YESTERDAY HAD A PRESS CONFERENCE
WHERE HE LAID OUT THE CRIMES FOR
THIS YEAR AND IT CONTINUES TO GO
DOWN YEAR AFTER YEAR.
IT'S AN EXTRA OR ANY EFFORT BY
THE NYPD USING POLICIES AND
STRATEGIES THAT I INSTIGATED IN
MY ADMINISTRATION.
HOW DO YOU HAVE 500,000 NEW JOBS
IN SIX YEARS, HOW DO YOU HAVE
RECORD NUMBER OF TOURISTS IF
IT'S THIS HORRIBLE HEALTH
GRAVEYARD IS DESCRIBED IN?
>> Tucker: YOU ARE ARGUING
ACROSS WHAT I AM SAYING.
SO IF THE CITY IS DOING SO WELL,
THEN YOU HAVE A NET INFLUENCE OF
PEOPLE INTO NEW YORK CITY.
NO, JUST THE OPPOSITE.
YOU LOST 40,000 PEOPLE IN THE
LAST YEAR.
>> WE HAVE LOST A .6 MILLION
RESIDENTS.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST POPULATION
IN OUR HISTORY.
THAT'S WHAT MATTERS.
PEOPLE ARE INVESTING IN A CITY
BECAUSE IT'S WORKING.
I'M THE FIRST TO SAY, BECAUSE I
DO LIVE HERE AND I FEEL
EVERYTHING, I'VE BEEN HERE FOR
DECADES AND DECADES, WE HAVE
THINGS TO WORK ON FOR SURE.
WE HAVE AREAS WHERE WE ATE ARE
NOT ABLE TO BE BUT WHEN YOU GO
BACK, DO PEOPLE CREATE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF NEW JOBS IN A
PLACE IS NOT WORKING QUESTION
MIKE ARNOLD THINKS OF.
>> Tucker: .
>> Tucker: MOST NEW YORKERS
ARE LIBERAL SO THEY AGREE WITH
YOU ON THE MACRO ISSUES.
I THINK IF YOU ARE TO SAY WHAT
IS BILL de BLASIO BELIEVE
THERE IS A LOT OF OVERLAP.
BUT IF YOU WERE TO ASK YOUR
AVERAGE NEW YORKER HAS
BILL de BLASIO HAS DONE SUCH A
GOOD JOB IN NEW YORK CITY THAT
HE IS ABLE TO RUN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD
SUGGEST?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S NOT THE QUESTION FOR THE
QUESTION IS, ESPECIALLY IN A
RACE FOR PRESIDENT, WHAT HAVE
YOU ACTUALLY DONE THAT MAKES YOU
ABLE TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
I'VE RUN THE BIGGEST MOST
COMPLEX CITY IN THIS COUNTRY AND
AGAIN IT'S THE SAFEST WE'VE EVER
BEEN, THE STRONGEST ECONOMY
WE'VE EVER BEEN IN, THE MOST
DIVERSE PLACE AND OUR SOCIAL
FABRIC IS A LOT YOUNGER THAN I
WAS SIX YEARS AGO, THERE'S A LOT
I CAN SHOW YOU THAT ACTUALLY IT
IS TO DO WITH HOW YOU CAN RUN
SOMETHING AND MOVE SOMETHING
FORWARD AND WHERE WE STARTED.
I'M TALKING ABOUT ISSUES RELATED
TO WORKING PEOPLE THAT BLUNTLY
NEITHER DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS
TALK ENOUGH ABOUT AND MY WHOLE
REASON FOR GOING FOR MAYOR WAS
TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF THE WORKING
PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
DONE IN THE CITY.
>> Tucker: SO THE BIGGEST
PRIVATE-SECTOR EMPLOYERS --
--
WHO ARE THEY?
CHASE IS NUMBER ONE.
JPMORGAN CHASE.
DOES THE LEADERSHIP --
SO OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE THE
BIGGEST PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYER
AND THE CITY THAT YOU RUN, THE
BIGGEST CITY IN AMERICA.
SO OBVIOUSLY THE HEAD OF THAT
COMPANY, JAMIE DIMON MUST BE A
HUGE SUPPORTER OF YOURS IN A BIG
DONOR TO YOUR PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
>> THIS LOGIC PATTERN DOESN'T
COLT HOLD.
THE QUESTION IS THIS.
WE HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS AND I
RESPECT HIM BUT WE HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWS PAID BY THE WAY,
CEO OF A MAJOR FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION IS THE LAST KIND OF
PERSON I THINK WOULD SUPPORT ME
BECAUSE I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO BE
TOUGHER ON WALL STREET.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO STAND UP
FOR WORKING PEOPLE.
I THINK WE NEED TO TAX THE
WEALTHY A LOT MORE THAN WE ARE.
I'M A PROGRESSIVE WHO CARES
ABOUT WORKING PEOPLE.
WHY WOULD YOU THINK THE CEO OF A
BANK WOULD SUPPORT SOMEONE LIKE
ME THAT IS CONCERNED ABOUT
WORKING PEOPLE AND MIDDLE-CLASS
PEOPLE NOT THE ONES OF THE TOP?
>> Tucker: BECAUSE YOU ARE THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY AND THEY HAVE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES
LIVING IN OUR CITY.
AT SOME POINT IT'S NOT
IDEOLOGICAL.
I DON'T THINK JAMIE DIMON THE
HEAD OF THE COMPANY AS A
CONSERVATIVE.
HE IS NOT.
IT IS NOT ABOUT THE IDEOLOGY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE BANK.
IT'S ABOUT WHETHER YOU ARE
MAKING THE CITY BETTER.
>> LOOK, I KNOW HIM AND I
RESPECT HIM AND I THINK HE OFTEN
SPEAKS ABOUT IMPORTANT ISSUES
BUT WE HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT
WORLD VIEW AND IT DOESN'T
SURPRISE ME THAT HE WOULD NOT
SUPPORT SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO TAX
THE WEALTHY A LOT MORE AND WANTS
TO CHALLENGE WALL STREET AND
BELIEVES THAT WE HAVE TO DO A
LOT MORE FOR WORKING PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT I'M ABOUT.
>> Tucker: NAME ONE BIG SECTOR
THAT SUPPORTS YOU.
CAN YOU NAME ONE QUESTION MIKE
>> I DON'T PLAY THESE GAMES.
THE QUESTION IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR TOO LONG
HAS BEEN WAY TOO COZY WITH
DONORS, WITH WALL STREET, WITH
FOLKS WHO ACTUALLY CREATED A LOT
OF OUR PROBLEMS.
THE WHOLE REASON WE ARE HAVING A
GOOD CONVERSATION ON AUTOMATION
IS BECAUSE I DON'T CARE ABOUT
WHAT THOSE DONORS THINK.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT WHAT FOLKS IN
SILICON VALLEY WERE TRYING TO
JUSTIFY THAT TECHNOLOGY SOMEHOW,
THEY ARE RESTING THEIR MORALS ON
THE UNIVERSAL BASIC IN INCOME
AND THIS IS ANOTHER FALLACY.
IT UBI, MAYBE IT'S PART OF A
SOLUTION IN SOME WAY, SHAPE, OR
FORM BUT WHAT I FEAR ABOUT THAT
KIND OF IDEA, IT IS A CRUSH.
IT IS A WAY FOR A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE TO MAKE A HUGE AMOUNT OF
MONEY TO MAKE THEIR OWN
CONSCIENCES FEEL BETTER ABOUT
IT'S GOING TO LEAD TO A FUTURE
WITHOUT WORK AND THE LAST THING
WE NEED, I MOVED PROGRESSIVE,
I'M A DEMOCRAT, I BELIEVE AND
WORK I BELIEVE WORK IS WHAT
PEOPLE AT A VALUE AND MEANING
AND WE NEED TO PROTECT WORK IN
THIS COUNTRY AND AS A WHOLE LOT
OF WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO ARE HAPPY
TO RUN ALL THE WAY TO THE BANK
AND THE WORKING PEOPLE TO HIDE
AND THEN THEY WILL SAY I'LL SEND
YOU A CHECK.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS BUT IT'S FOR
ON YOUR RIGHT HERE BY THE WAY,
IF YOU'VE EVER KNOWN INHERITED
MONEY PEOPLE, THEY ARE THE
UNHAPPIEST PEOPLE IN AMERICA SO
OBVIOUSLY YOU DON'T WANT TO
ENCOURAGE ENDLESS.
QUICK FINAL QUESTION.
HOW CAN YOU TAKE AN SUV TO THE
GYM AND BACK EVERY DAY AND SAY
THAT YOU ARE REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE?
>> IS A CHRYSLER PACIFICA.
IT'S A PACIFIC AVENUE.
IT'S A HYBRID ELECTRIC.
IT'S NOT AN SUV FIRST OF ALL.
BUT IT LOOKS, I COME FROM A
NEIGHBORHOOD, I GO BACK TO MY
NEIGHBORHOOD ALL THE TIME.
IT'S THE WEIGHTS AND MEANS THAT
I STAY CONNECTED TO PEOPLE AND
THAT I'M ABLE TO HAVE A ROUTINE
THAT ALLOWS ME TO BE 24/7 THE BA
THAT ALLOWS ME TO BE 24/7 THE BI
CAN
BE.
TUCKER, HE HAS A GREAT PART
ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
IF I'M IN A SUBWAY --
THE POINT IS, WHEREVER I GO, IF
I TAKE A SUBWAY, THE CARS FOLLOW
ME FOR SECURITY REASONS.
ANYWAY YOU SLIDE IT, I'M DOING
WHAT'S GOING TO HELP ME BE THE
BEST I CAN BE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
THE CITY AND THAT'S WHY I AM
PROUD TO SAY THIS IS A CITY JUST
SAFEST BIG CITY THAT IS MOVING
FORWARD IN SO MANY WAYS BUT IF
WE DON'T GET THESE BIGGER ISSUES
RIGHT, I GOT TO TELL YOU, YOU
CAN BE MADE, YOU CAN FEEL LIKE
I'M ABLE TO DO THINGS BUT AT
WASHINGTON DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT CITIES AND
STATES CAN'T DO, IF WASHINGTON
DOESN'T ADDRESS THIS AUTOMATION
ISSUE, WE ARE ALL SCREWED BEER
WE ARE ALL SCREWED.
THIS BETTER BE A 2020 ISSUE AND
IT'S NOT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S NOT A 2020 ISSUE AND WE
NEED TO MAKE IT A 2020 ISSUE.
>> Tucker: WE ARE GOING TO